well germany is marking the one-year
anniversary of a deadly anti-semitic
attack on a synagogue in the eastern
city of hulla
the attacker failed to breach the
synagogue's front door but
gunned down two people outside dw spoke
to one woman who narrowly escaped that
of the attack that day
the attacker came to the synagogue to
the exact same spot i just walked out
the exact same door and he started
shooting it down
life is now before and after before the
attack
and after the attack molly sharpman
escaped death by a stroke of fortune on
october 9
2019 in the city of hala a heavily armed
attacker arrived around noon to the
local synagogue
planning to break in and shoot the
jewish congregation during yom kippur
prayers
she missed the assailant by only a few
minutes
after stepping out for some fresh air in
a nearby park
shortly before he arrived
in my imagination it felt farther away
like i was oh the park is far away it's
protected but actually when i went back
i realized it was
so much closer the close call of this is
just
beyond comprehension as things got back
to normal actually things that's when
things got
more difficult so slowly i started
feeling kind of symptoms
really hard to keep up with everything
a lot of stress and anxiety
a few months after the attack molly was
diagnosed with post-traumatic stress
disorder
she started treatment and at the same
time found great comfort in the very
target of the attack
her jewish identity and community
the communal events such as prayers and
singing are part of her therapy
singing is my connection is part one of
my connections to judaism
and if you look at some of these words
they're really connected to kind of what
i went through of like
you know um
that even in the hard times god is there
this connection that god is
standing by me even in the more
difficult times
no matter what happens a year after the
attack the alleged perpetrator has gone
on trial in the city of magdeburg
molly sharfman was the first witness to
give testimony in front of the judges
in her statement she referred to her
family history
my grandfather went through a very
terrible thing he lost his whole family
in the holocaust and he was able to live
and live a life
and you know give us love and he
was a cantor and he loved judaism he
taught us judaism
i was very close to him so that's what
made me feel the strongest was this
connection with him and i felt it was
important to share that in the court
and that is resilience
molly sharpman says her grandfather was
the only member of the family to survive
the holocaust
but hala has also made a survivor out of
her
every year on yom kippur her grandfather
would say a prayer for his granddaughter
in hopes of protecting her from any harm
she says on october 9
2019 his hopes were fulfilled
this attacker this person cannot take
away what my grandfather taught me what
my grandfather gave me i stood at my own
two feet
i'm strong and i was able to stand in
front of a person who
has so much hate and tried to hurt us
to be able to like say to him you messed
with the wrong people
the attack in hollow is the most serious
anti-semitic attack in
post-reunification germany
but it's also part of a worrying trend
the interior ministry says crimes
motivated by anti-semitism
have risen steadily in recent years
reaching a high of more than
two thousand cases last year just last
sunday a man was assaulted and wounded
outside a synagogue in hamburg
police confirmed that the motive was
anti-semitism
last month chancellor angela merkel said
it was a cause of great concern
to her that many jews no longer feel
safe in germany
for more on this i'm joined by marina
weisbund she's a member of the german
green party and also a member of the
jewish
community here in berlin thanks very
much for joining us
as we just heard anti-semitism is on the
rise and germany's foreign minister
says it's the biggest threat in the
country do you feel that in your daily
life
i feel and many friends tell me that
we are more afraid of being jewish in
germany today
than we have been half a year ago or a
year ago
this trend started to rise a couple of
years ago
um being uh
being forced by the platforms by social
media where anti-semitic conspiracy
theories
thrive uh so the attack on halo
was not a surprise to many we were
rather expecting
when will something happen and where
will something happen
and we are expecting the next terror
attacks today
as the likes of q anon spread around the
globe telling anti-semitic conspiracy
theories
that certainly is alarming i mean it's
been a year since the attack
now in hala has germany been doing
enough
i don't think that germany has been
doing enough we are particularly
concerned with
the far-right extremist views within the
police because whenever i receive death
threats or
rape threats what i do is i go to the
police
but we are now learning of more and more
police stations
where right wing radical chats
groups preparation groups have been
uncovered
and the ministers of the interior aren't
doing a very good job
at uncovering these structures on the
contrary they are saying that we do not
need studies because the police has no
problem of racism and uh the synagogues
aren't protected well enough
and where they are um the uh
minister president has uh been saying
stalking
has been saying well the police are
needed elsewhere as well
and because we have to protect the jews
basically
we cannot react as fast to calls of the
police
from the other citizens well not doing
enough then
what do you say germany should be doing
to tackle the problem
i think that we need to look at the
larger structural issues that
is um antisemitic and racist structures
within the police
that is um what is going on on social
media monitor it more closely understand
these groups
more closely and act before words and
humor
turn into violence because right now
police is not taking uh very seriously
what is happening
online because it doesn't seem real
marina weiss bund member of the german
green party thanks very much for
speaking to deutsche baha
you